in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast I am your host
David so I'm your other host George it's
acaba bbbb man man man so we got some
very interesting topics today that
everybody wanted us to hop on so
originally I was just gonna do this on
my channel but I'm like wait we got a
[ __ ] podcast dude I'm gonna talk
about it so the first thing that we're
just gonna get right into it
you know who brother nature is yes so
brother nature I don't forgot what his
real [ __ ] name is but he's that he's
a light-skinned dude that talks to beers
and [ __ ] you know Canella okay come on
cannellini like you've got carrots of
[ __ ] and he's like the dude that's how I
think this how he popped off with the
deers and [ __ ] yeah and he's like
playing with all kinds of animals I mean
he was really hot on Twitter for a
minute yeah he I think he still is so he
was doing stuff with like I think the
first video that I saw it wasn't even a
deer videos him in like pigeons or some
[ __ ] yeah New York it's [ __ ] funny
yeah like I was cracking the [ __ ] up and
I used to follow him I stopped on him
because I guess I got kind of got tired
of his cuz he was doing the same thing
with different animals yes over a year
and do it I was like okay he's doing the
same [ __ ] over and over it's like a
Canela yeah alright I'm done with this
cuz I started following the real Tarzan
and so on and that [ __ ] he like
he knows his [ __ ] about animals and so I
got really like stuck onto him so I kind
of moved on from that
but recently everybody's been sending me
this [ __ ] so there's a video clip of him
getting his [ __ ] ass beat at the
sandwich shop like jumped like by a
monkey
no no cuz I was picturing him like he
just he [ __ ] up like Steve Irwin you
know like laughs who [ __ ] up well he
[ __ ] up on this one too so there was
an original video came out and I tweeted
us like yeah who the [ __ ] would beat up
brother nature right he's such a nice
like passive was he doing that to people
so check this [ __ ] out
come here so there's a video that was
put out of him getting jumped right I'm
talking about like they kicked his ass
in in the [ __ ] sandwich shop it was
late at night I think he's like a 6 a.m.
or something don't quote me on this
these are all just you know from us in
pieces but you know after they [ __ ]
him up a little bit sock him in the face
they threw like what like drinks at his
face
ketchup and condiments and all this
other stuff then it cuts to a clip of
him outside and the news like straight
up Street stomping him like stomping on
his home like American history Xing his
ass yeah and then he was like covering
up like this he wasn't moving or
anything so I was like yo he's not even
fighting back why the [ __ ] would these
guys beat him up yeah but as we all know
there's two sides to every phone so you
know for me I'm trying to be funny I'm
like yeah who the [ __ ] would [ __ ] him up
like that's that's like a fast way
ticket to hell so you know people were
cracking up to stuff and um but of
course I didn't know the full story so I
was kind of curious to see where's the
rest of the footage I'm pretty sure
everybody was right but all the footage
the only footage that I could see at the
time was of him getting beat up well
later on somebody released the whole si
CCTV footage of the whole altercation oh
and the whole altercation is crazy so I
send it to your phone
so check it out okay all right we got a
watch then watch this [ __ ] and you guys
are gonna watch it with this if you guys
are out there in a podcast land you
obviously won't be able to see it but
we'll talk you through it okay hold on
you sent it to okay yeah so it has like
subtitle you need the volume on it
there's like two videos check the first
one so this is the full video footage of
what actually happened so before it was
cut up it went for footage of him inside
getting beat up but somebody recorded
and then there was footage of him
outside getting beat up getting recorded
so there's a two-minute video yeah so
watch this [ __ ] alright three two one
give me your phone so just give me your
phone he's walking up to him give me
your phone or else I said please give me
your phone or else so this wasn't in the
original footage like the confrontation
they just those the footage of him just
getting beat up you just want me to call
my dear now well that's how you got
jokes oh oh you know when the flannel
comes off just about to go down right
never mind so that guy works at the
sandwich shop and he's telling him to
leave yeah he's just about to go down
and this is like a late-night spot yeah
okay so he confronted them and he
started all this [ __ ] made him all
pissed off
and then that's where the video started
mm-hmm he's like dead man he go he
points at him he goes dead man dead man
and that wasn't in the original footage
cuz it was the phone from that was him
recording I think saying dead man dead
man pointing at them then it goes into
this video him getting [ __ ] up and
this is the video you saw yep stop boom
dude get his head stopped in yeah damn
he got kicked in the head yep and now I
think they're going back into the
sandwich shop he comes back inside to
fight a friend after getting his ass
whupped outside he oh oh no oh so he
came back and attacked um started
swinging on a [ __ ] and then his
friends came oh so his friends came to
the rescue so this is the only footage
that I saw prior with ya without any
context so he sucker-punched the other
friend mm-hmm what is he doing there
alone he was actually with the girl so
later on you'll find out what the
sandwich shop releases in terms of
information about what really happened
and they said that though one of the
guys say that there was like condiments
in space so apparently he they recorded
him with his girl and they're like oh
you always [ __ ] like you know the guy
Oh give me your phone I don't want that
footage oh they should be bossing up on
them well I mean maybe he was cheating
or something and he didn't want or I
don't know he just felt uncomfortable
but it's like hey we deal with that [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] time do ya people will
report like we'll be eating and
obviously they're [ __ ] recording us
I'll flip them off or all peace or
whatever depending on how I feel and I'm
like what the [ __ ] bro I see this [ __ ]
yeah don't be weird
come over here and ask me for a picture
but I don't know like I think people
just they're just screwing around
they're [ __ ] around or like hey it's
him let's record it yeah it's not a big
deal so this is a statement that fee so
it's called la sandwich sandwich Cherie
Brickell is where the spots called and
it's La sandwich or me it might be last
sandwich or something listen Florida so
it's La sandwich shop either that or I'm
[ __ ] it all up but this is the
statement that they put out on their
Instagram he goes
here's what really happened brother
nature and a female friend of his were
angry at someone who recognized him and
took a video of them yeah they wanted
the guide to delete the video he did not
give them his phone so brother nature
said he want to take it outside our
employee tries to keep them separated
the one inside and one outside after a
few minutes brother nature comes back
rushing inside the store and starts
attacking a totally different guy
brother nature started the entire
altercation yeah the the problem with
this I think people got really pissed
off at was that he didn't really deny
the fact that he was saying anything but
he just kind of he made it sound as if
he was not he didn't do anything to
antagonize them to find anything he did
anything wrong because then because all
the footage that was being released made
it seem like he was just getting jumped
and beat up by some random dudes yeah
maybe because he was a famous guy but he
said dead man dead man exactly that
wasn't released until later so that's a
threat it's a threat so it's in the way
he got up in their space mm-hmm the way
he like he you could clearly tell he
those two guys weren't sure about
[ __ ] his ass up game a couple chances
yeah I'm pretty sure if he went up and
he was like yell man like that ain't
cool man
you gotta delete that and let's just say
like he was stepping out on his girl
right it's like a bro Real Talk I'm
actually that's the back side my side
shakes yeah at least that video I get
[ __ ] like you mind like taking it down
I'm personally like I got you man and
they would have put it down or something
yeah and I'd be like y'all take a
picture with you guys right here but you
got to delete that man but this is like
in a clear example of like kind of like
the internet gone wrong right because we
all kind of just make assumptions
without knowing the facts and even for
me when I tweeted that [ __ ] obviously I
knew there was there had to be more to
this but I just made a quick joke out of
it but people were so mad they're mad at
you they no they weren't mad at those
other guys cuz they're like I can't
believe you would beat up this guy who's
just trying to save the earth because
that's his MO
yeah but man everybody got a little bit
of evil and everybody got a little bit
of good you know [ __ ] juicy small
yato's dude yeah to see smoke you [ __ ]
juicy so you see small yeah yeah so he
kind of like I don't know if he really
created the backstory I think his fans
kind of did you know his innocence but
he didn't deny it either
this guy plays with monkeys there's no
way he could be doing this that's the
funny thing too it's is how people
believe that just because somebody has
his
like this persona online it means that
they just can never do any wrong most of
the people that we know are the most
scoundrel [ __ ] on earth are the
most innocent people oh for sure dude I
know the ones that enjoy gating hookers
and the ones that love doing lots and
lots of alcoholic beverages to the point
where hey maybe you got a problem bro if
not us it's not us we got all that [ __ ]
out of our system I talk about it openly
I don't give a [ __ ] it's not a big
surprise if I fight somebody at a
sandwich shop it's a bigger surprise if
I say hey man let's not fight yeah you
know like or if I'm the guy that's like
you know what it's Friday night 9 p.m.
I'm gonna call it quits I'm gonna go to
sleep they don't expect that from us ok
every time we do shows or whatever
they'll be like hey you guys want to
smoke some weed yeah you want to do some
coke you what do you guys want you want
us to take you to the bar and we're like
nah I might take me to a dope restaurant
mmm let's have some good conversation
and I'm asleep at 10 p.m. like I'm good
for me now cuz I have a fiance so what's
the point of me going down there like
literally this podcast is brought to you
by Vistaprint my friends check it out I
decided not to leave my holiday cards to
the last minute this year and so I went
to vistaprint to order custom cards and
it was so easy to make something that I
know my friends and family would love to
get I honestly can't wait for people to
see them and hang them up this season
man holiday cards are the best man ring
a ding a ding a ling oh ok look if you
want to pick a shape like square or
rounded corners folded or flat and then
choose one of vista prince designs
they've got everything from fun and
festive to gorgeous eye catching lungs
next you can put your favorite picture
right there on most of the options and
even upload a great shot right from your
phone then just figure out how many you
need and order them with time to spare I
love it what are you waiting for people
vistaprint has hundreds of card designs
from timeless classes to fund new trends
Vistaprint also has custom calendars for
gifts that keep giving all year round
all custom cards and calendars are up to
50% off right now you can also upload
your favorite photos right from your
phone and save on mugs canvases and
other photo gifts your satisfaction is
100% guaranteed or they'll make it right
either by reprinting your order or by
offering a refund so this season make
more merry at Vistaprint comm with up to
50% off all holiday cards and photo
calendars plus great deals on photo
gifts at vistaprint.com
just enter promo code brain 50 but
that's vistaprint.com promo code brain
50 offer expires January 5th I don't
know man but it's funny that they get
they kind of everyone's filling in the
blanks right yeah oh I bet you they're
[ __ ] wild the way that they talked
like on Jay King news they must be wild
and I'm like no I don't have to that is
my wild like being able to speak openly
yeah we just did the show in Boston
right and then one of the questions were
like you know y'all like seemed like you
you give a lot of your private life and
you talked openly about everything and
they're like when do you feel like when
what is like do you even have any
private life left for yourself do you
feel like everything's out in the public
and I'm like nah I keep a lot of [ __ ]
private so the things that I'm talking
about I'm fine with people finding out
yeah but at the same time it's kind of
fun talking about all this [ __ ] yeah and
I think sometimes too people forget that
I think because our foundation is comedy
if we don't talk about our personal
lives there's no truth in the things
that we say so we we have to talk about
that stuff either that under start I'm
gonna just start making up [ __ ] mm-hmm
so at that point being a comic and being
somebody who's allowed to speak about
the personal experiences there's a
reason why we have these type of
platforms if we don't do that that we
got nothing
we're [ __ ] did you hear how the the
private jokes that we got is so much
good [ __ ] [ __ ] from our family too and
that shit's private like I think there's
a lot of funny [ __ ] [ __ ] that I will
tell you guys in private yeah but we're
not gonna air that [ __ ] out to the
public to hear cuz that would embarrass
them I embarrassed me yeah so my mom
gets embarrassed of me
but I'm not gonna roast her on air or
anybody so I think that's where I draw
the line yeah and the stuff that we tell
about our family or friends or stuff
like that I mean there's a reason why I
don't say names on this and there's also
a reason why even when I do say names
those names aren't real they're all fake
names I'm not gonna give you the names
of people that I [ __ ] know except for
like you know you guys see my best
friend like gobble or something he's
he's come on in this platform so you're
like oh I can't believe you just out of
that person's name it's like that wasn't
their actual name yeah like I'm just
telling you these stories because
stories are there but I still have to
keep certain things private you don't
damn and here I was I thought they were
real names I'll be like oh so you're
that [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] and
they're like nah that wasn't me Oh same
name okay never [ __ ] a DJ Park [ __ ]
you this is actual [ __ ] named trash
bag let me tell you where's addresses
but oh my god he decided to get his name
rented under somebody else's name and he
decided not to pay the rent and he lied
that he switched the the title but he
didn't so DJ parked you can go [ __ ]
suck a fat dick you son of a [ __ ] Oh
- people are [ __ ] funny dude yeah so
he's been getting quite some heat about
this and it's funny cuz like when I see
this [ __ ] it's kind of like yo man I
think that's why I like the fact that we
can just kind of be ourselves on our
platforms we don't have to live like a
duplicitous life no so for him maybe he
has to be like yo Canela whatever I'm at
he saved the earth cuz it's a character
that's like if I was uncle chin 24/7
yeah you know hey everybody how's all
the [ __ ] people in a way of
doing [ __ ] okay today we gonna
talk about Brad a nature yo that was
like oh what's his name
[ __ ] he's an actor now from Canada
Asian guy he's young Peter Chao Peter
Chao I didn't know that that was a
character because he did it all the time
yeah hey Pete that child here yeah yeah
so but that was a character here yeah
and he did it so well after when I first
watched his stuff I thought that's
actually who he was so I was like look
at his trash bag dude making Asian
people look bad and then later on
they're like no that's a character I was
like he was trolling I was like oh
that's [ __ ] genius yeah that's like
what we try to do but we had too many
characters and it was like obviously
because we couldn't do the same trope
over and over now and I think yeah he
did he overplayed the trope yeah and I
think that's why his character started
dying out really early on yeah cuz he
was poppin off around the same time we
were but he disappeared a lot faster
because he just kept doing the same
thing over and over and over he got
involved
yeah but he's an actor now he was in oh
that wool Assassins Netflix show oh no
[ __ ] yeah he's my friend we chat online
he's like come come to Vancouver man oh
yeah he was he told us all all the
[ __ ] book a venue out there and just
[ __ ] do a show with them I'm like a
man that might not be a bad idea out
here getting so random
Vancouver [ __ ] I know Peter Chao you
want to dim sum to shiny balls you want
to hog out nutsack Chinese tampering man
oh [ __ ] you might like this kid brother
nature though man it's funny like I
don't understand it's like you are you
are at a certain place in your life
where things are [ __ ] good right let
me just put it in perspective for this
kid you got big off of talking to deer
yeah and you somehow bought a Lambo with
that money with really yeah with like
bran deals or whatever but he made good
money like he was balling like kid
bought a Lambo and [ __ ] so it's like
okay how did when you're young and
you're that successful it tends to [ __ ]
you up a lot excuse your perception I
think when you're young and successful
you're you're not because you haven't
had a lot of life experience it's hard
for you to be grateful for the things
that are coming in it's just more like
oh this is dope this is dope this is
dope and things get carried away because
I don't know why you thought that you
talking to deer and then you also have
like this little hook and bible
scripture chest tattoo thing going on
there suddenly you're a thug like you
get like you down to throw down and [ __ ]
it might be like I mean who knows I
think the real culprit might be his
girlfriend you know oh maybe she might
be like they're taking pictures of him
make him stop and he's all like
[ __ ] ain't gonna I'm not a [ __ ] I'm not
gonna back down I'm a [ __ ] man yeah
and he comes up a man taking a turn that
[ __ ] off and they're like [ __ ] you he's
like oh [ __ ] now gonna be a man and [ __ ]
yeah I don't know making up filling on
Blake's you know well the weird thing
was his approach was so [ __ ]
aggressive like he came out to him as I
yell give me your like yeah your phone
how old is he like 18 or 19 years young
as [ __ ] right so you know when you're a
barking Chihuahua you don't know how to
talk to people cuz you're scared so the
only way you know how to do is like
thousand percent hoping that you can
intimidate someone to do something for
you
yeah like the whole thing like give me
your phone it's like oh sure you ready
[ __ ] up problem yeah you there's so
many different ways you can do but he
was probably like you know like he
probably thought he could intimidate or
do something stupid he's too skinny to
intimidate though yeah and he has like
those veneers in it four teeth in his
head I bet you he was like yeah imma go
boo to him I'm gonna say give me your
phone if I could delete that [ __ ] be
like don't [ __ ] with me man and I'm
gonna walk away like a champion dude his
teeth look like piano keys like you know
he's scared of that [ __ ] dude [ __ ]
ridiculous like the kid has lost his
mind man it's like you're already put
out as a nice guy and people know who
you are like you're mr. deer dude yeah
and then now you're gonna come up and
square up on somebody like you're a thug
yeah that's not gonna work out like that
and it's your fault if you're that
famous you're [ __ ] eating a Tele
sandwiches should get post mates or do
something you got money bro man if
you're real famous like it's difficult
to do average people [ __ ] like that
because that should happen you know you
know what it reminds me of you ever like
you know like those [ __ ] um those
kids who have a like a really good life
like they they're the ones their family
have money or whatever but they're the
ones trying to join gangs it get down
and do like some dirty [ __ ]
oh yeah broke it's like yo man I think
poor people are trying to be you like
why are you doing the opposite cuz money
doesn't teach them anything I think just
because they have money yeah like
remember that word affluenza oh yeah
yeah like like they're so [ __ ] rich
that they don't have a connection to our
reality or whatever so they'll do [ __ ]
like crash a Lambo and
ah [ __ ] it and they walk away from it do
some crazy things like that like their
perception is so [ __ ] skewed yeah
and I think like when the real world
gets to check you like that that's when
you know you probably start to hopefully
you'll get a reality check because you
he he went up to two guys thinking that
he was gonna what [ __ ] him up like I
think he was like ah [ __ ] when he
realized he had homies yeah and in the
funny thing is he got his ass beat
outside and he decided to come back in
for another ass woman and [ __ ] up his
friend and he got caught in between oh
my god dude it's so stupid man like I
don't I guess like when you're young too
it's kind of hard for you to back down
cuz your pride is probably oh man that
would have been me yeah I would I
wouldn't have even taken outside I'm
like there's two guys alright maybe if I
could take one then I could get the
other one [ __ ] it and I'll go and I'll
probably get beat by both of them and a
third friend that punches me at the back
of my head cuz I didn't know he was
there I honestly like if you if you want
to put it into perspective let's say if
it was a situation where I had a [ __ ]
Throwdown I wouldn't have used my fists
there was cherished there there was a
table you could have [ __ ] you so much
[ __ ] if you're trying to teach him how
to actually function up yeah well yeah
because like at that point - and here's
the thing man like I'm not a tough guy
but you know I grew up in a relatively
bad neighborhood so at that point when
you're when you're getting into a fight
like this this isn't the [ __ ] movies
man like one of my older homies - he
goes dude if you go into a fight and
people are trying to hurt you you need
to go in like you're trying to kill them
yeah because they don't give a [ __ ]
about you so you're trying to do this
whole thing of like yeah I'm a man I
throw down with my fists [ __ ] that no
that's how you die two on one juice
anything and everything cuz it's
survival at that yeah so I it's weird
people have died from just getting
jumped you get head smash head kicked
all that he's lucky he all he got was
like a fat lip like nothing else
happened they weren't done I mean it
looked like pretty bad outside but he
had enough energy to run back in and and
get [ __ ] up again so he was lucky cuz
they just you know they popped him a few
times stepped on his head and they just
walked away yeah
they didn't make sure that he was down
and out so I think they kind of got
their anger out that I [ __ ] this loser
and they went back inside and then all
of a sudden he gets you I you're alone
they're like what the [ __ ] I getting
myself into situations where I'm like oh
[ __ ] now I got a fight now I got a fight
[ __ ]
I didn't even water what happened you
know wife is always a homie that [ __ ] it
start some [ __ ] and yeah I guess I have
to get down that's one or like if
someone saw me get disrespected and then
always this always got me in high school
you gonna let him do that to you dawg I
guess not like you know why'd you say
that out loud fool man I had this one
guy he was like ching chang chong ching
chang chong and I was like [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up man and then they looked and
his other guy was like you let him say
that you dog no oh [ __ ] man I would let
him say that to me and all these people
started gathering around I'm like oh
[ __ ] you man like what you gonna do
about it
and I just popped him in his [ __ ]
face and he stopped and he held his
mouth and he ran into the [ __ ]
special boy building ya know I had no
idea cuz I'm all like dude it was like
like she john ching chong I'm like oh my
god this guy's [ __ ] racist dude [ __ ]
this guy and then like just one guy's
egging it all you gonna let him saying
[ __ ] to man gonna let us say that [ __ ]
and it was a who's fight fight and I'm
all like man [ __ ] you and I pushed on he
was gonna [ __ ] you and he pushed me as
like change change change change change
I just said [ __ ] and I just popped him
in his face and they're like oh and then
they're trying to get to him like you
don't do that you go bro like what's up
and he just stared at me and he held his
mouth and he ran and ran straight to the
special building dude he ran straight
inside did everybody else no I think
everyone was like wait wha and in days
I'm running and it I think it everyone
just cuz no one gets into a fight gets
popped and just holds their face like
this and stops yeah and with his mouth
wide [ __ ] open and then immediately
run straight into this special class and
everyone looks at each other and they're
like oh he's special doc he's special
and I was like that's like one of those
weird situations where either way you
would have lost because it's like either
one you either sock the mentally
challenged kid or you got punked by them
into I didn't know you was mentally
challenged that's the same [ __ ] that it
didn't happen to me like that but I
remember I was being mean and races I
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was saying
that was when I was in seventh grade I
went to this junior high school called
James rudder and next to my algebra
class there was the special ed class was
right across I was going to the bathroom
and when I came out I mean I remember
this [ __ ] like it was yesterday because
it reminded me of like of like a zombie
situation so I'm coming out the bathroom
about to go to class and I see one of
these like mentally challenged kids I
think that's the PC term she looks at me
and I [ __ ] you [ __ ] not he just
starts screaming and I'm running at me
Oh blah oh [ __ ] and so I'm sitting there
and I remembered the first thing that I
thought was I had a couple of options
number one I'm either gonna have to run
away from this mentally challenging and
notice the [ __ ] that ran away from a
mentally challenged I would rat or two
whatever or two I'm gonna have to knock
out this [ __ ] clothes line is
like [ __ ] sock this mental challenge
even known as a dude that beat up a
mentally challenged kids what did you do
so I got [ __ ] lucky because when I
came out the bathroom that it was one of
the the Khan campus security that was
there and right when he's about to run
through and like oh [ __ ] I froze the guy
[ __ ] grabbed the kids last minute I
was going to take him at his stomach oh
I was gonna tech one dough back straight
kick him in the gut I had a [ __ ]
white duck and just kick this
[ __ ] out the way Taekwondo style
I don't know that's what you could it
did you could have done so many
things like grab him like I was gonna
[ __ ] kick the [ __ ] out of him because
I only thing I was thinking about is
like you know everybody all my homies
are gonna make fun of me for running
away from this kid like from running
away yeah you do stupid [ __ ] when you're
a kid for pride exactly you do stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and that's what I'm
saying is like if this dudes like 18 oh
man I can't say [ __ ] cuz I did stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and so I probably
would too if I've my pride would still
was hurt
cuz we're also holding I think when
people look in attitude they're kind of
holding him up to like I said
everybody's responsible for the things
that they've done but if I see a young
person do some [ __ ] like that I'm like
that's some young stupid [ __ ] yeah it's
not to excuse his behavior but
everybody's like oh I look up to you
it's like why do you that's your fault
you look up to a guy that talks to
[ __ ] deer and goes yeah and then he
like cleans up beaches here and there
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying that's what
every [ __ ] blonde white surfer does
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah you know what is his [ __ ] real
name look at his real name
brother nature yeah I know he was still
relevant or he was around yeah Instagram
another shits popping that's why it
always blows my mind when people are
like oh these guys are role models and
I'm like for what what I don't know look
Calvin Pena is his name Oh Calvin pin
yeah deer squad he likes to feed the
deer I guess so I know there's a video
on me getting jumped everyone in the
piece of shot literally just watched
with their phones out and did nothing
that's why that's what he tweeted when
he got when that video came out stooop
they were probably watching you like you
deserved it you face exactly everybody
was eating and relaxing and you had to
start some [ __ ] ain't that some [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] I think the his problem is
that he took the moral high ground yeah
you put out that thing like everybody is
uh-uh
the [ __ ] losers just watch me get
beat up it's like I'm so famous but no
one came to my rescue it's like maybe
you shouldn't appointed at people and
said dead dead that's so [ __ ] exactly
who says dead man dead man but once you
say dead man that means you're you
threatened to kill them yeah I was like
bro you're lucky you got out alive yeah
what do you this ain't the [ __ ] this
ain't a [ __ ]
okay that's what I'm saying like I think
these fools watch these young kids they
watch a lot of you know TV and yeah all
this [ __ ] they got all this bravado
about them but if you [ __ ] with the
wrong person in the wrong neighborhood
you say dead man they're gonna [ __ ]
blast you bro yeah lucky that's like I'm
gonna get you before you get me and this
[ __ ] was in Miami to our mind is [ __ ]
crazy
he's lucky there's a lot of summer there
kokin alligators and big butts that's
[ __ ] crazy man some of you young cats
do I think they have really good strip
clubs there guys you guys should just go
and get a lap dance relax grab a butt or
something if you're allowed to you know
there's a lot of things that booty does
to a man that relaxes him or excites him
but always in a great way not in a
non-violent way I always believe let's
let's just try to keep things peaceful
cuz I don't like to get angry this
podcast is brought to you by story worth
man I love family family is something
that's very important to me and having
things like memorabilia to remember them
by and to really get to know them is is
something that's just near and dear to
my heart I think that as technology
progresses a lot of the new technologies
that's coming out is kind of like taking
us away from developing strong
relationship and ties with family
well story worth actually does the
opposite of that there's it really kind
of connects you to your family and gives
them a really great gift so if you don't
know what I'm talking about let me tell
you a little bit about what story worth
is story worth is an online service that
helps your loved ones
tell the story of their lives through
thought-provoking questions about their
memories and personal thoughts so every
week a story worth emails your family
member different story prompts questions
like you probably wouldn't ask like you
know what have been some of your life's
greatest surprises and what's one of the
riskiest things you've ever done and
after one year story worth will compile
every answered question and photo you
choose to include into a beautiful
keepsake book that shipped for free now
there's a lot of stuff that you just
don't know that story worth will uncover
so this data collects and that that dope
keepsake book is something that you keep
as a
family memorabilia which I really do
enjoy I think anything that kind of
works with like tech and also on top of
that with family is something that I
like because I think that a lot of
people are going away from that and
story worth really does a great job of
answering or acts asking the right
questions that gets you to know your
family members better and connects words
and stories with with with photos that
gives you this this this warmth and in a
gift that you get like it you're gonna
get something that's gonna surprise you
at the end and that's why I just love it
so preserve and pass on memories with
story worth the most meaningful gift for
your family sign up today by going to
story worth com genius brain and you'll
get $20 off your first purchase that
story worth comm slash genius brain for
$20 off once again sign up today by
going to story worth comm slash genius
brain and you'll get $20 off your first
purchase today that story worth comm
slash genius brain for $20 off that's so
[ __ ] funny too in the fun even forgot
in the video he actually told him to
come outside so he told him to come out
and fight outside he's the one that in
and and instigated that yeah he probably
saw that do that man like when you start
[ __ ] cuz see I get like biting off more
than you can chew right like I get that
like I done that [ __ ] million times
where I'm like oh I wasn't ready for
this well [ __ ] it I gotta do it now you
know like whatever but at the end of it
I take my [ __ ] beating like a gene
you know I mean like it's like [ __ ] I
lost we move on like I think it's even
more embarrassing to get beat and be
like that's right [ __ ] I [ __ ] you
three up and it's like you're on the
floor what are you talking about there's
a lot of people who do that [ __ ] yeah or
like they go you're gonna do nothing
it's like you started it you [ __ ]
moral when I am Mariola and I I think I
told us on the podcast before but Muriel
and I had this one situation where it
was the first time she actually ever
seen me like angry enough to hit
somebody before that's because when I
was driving there's a couple of reasons
why I got so angry number one
I was already having the worst [ __ ]
month of my life I just dipped like
$10,000 into this like Korean short that
did not do well like this whole [ __ ]
thing but I was driving and when I was
driving I was talking to my mom on the
phone and this guy cuts me off and
almost like fears me off the road and
I'm really what everybody's like [ __ ]
I give him the finger and I kind of move
on so the guy comes up then he rolls
down and I just hear this baby like
honking behind me and then when he
pulled up this side he's holding his
horn or whatever and you know he's like
roll down your window roll down your
window and I'm like what the [ __ ] and I
roll down my window and I'm really calm
at this point and I'm Ariel was right
next to me and I go I was like what's up
right he goes [ __ ] pull over right
now so I could beat your [ __ ] ass or
something along that line yeah I just
remember I just like that was the first
time Ariel actually saw me get angry I
know what you I'm gonna [ __ ] you up I
looked at if I went I don't know what
the [ __ ] I said but it just went from
regular David to Sacramento eighteen
year old David you know just [ __ ]
curse and you know drop him whatever I
was saying and the dude was like oh [ __ ]
if he like started freaking out a little
bit cuz you know I think he's the one
that wanted to fight exactly Wow so that
started getting me even more angry and I
remember I was like hold on a second and
like all this like when I look back in
it now all this old anger when I was
younger started popping up right it's
like you thought you could do that to me
because number one I'm an Asian dude
with glasses so you thought I was her
and I'm in this car so you thought I was
a little [ __ ] cuz you see this asian
dude with some [ __ ] glasses too
you're gonna try to pick on me but then
when he heard me speak and get loud I
was like let's [ __ ] go okay so we got
to the point where I started chasing him
yeah all the way around oh my god then I
started slamming on my brakes and his
window was still down I'm like what
where the [ __ ] are you go and you told
me to pull over let's [ __ ] go and so
eventually what happened was he split
into another intersection and he bounced
and he left so I was so [ __ ] mad
because I didn't even get to [ __ ] him up
yeah because he was asking to throw down
and I just remember at that moment a
little [ __ ] what a [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz he
threatened me he said he wanted me to
pull over so I was like let's [ __ ] go
and so I remember Mariel was like you
need to calm down
she was super disappointed oh yeah she
was it was more like isn't it funny when
girlfriends don't go like man you're
such a man they look at you and they go
I felt terrible because you know she
grew up in a very nice area she don't
even know what that is
she don't know what that [ __ ] is and so
she never heard me speak like that she
never heard me get that angry before
yeah and I think like she was scared
yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] like I
forget there's somebody else important
next to me and so I under like calm my
[ __ ] ego down and yeah what the [ __ ]
was I doing like I was gonna [ __ ] go
crazy and they she asked me later on
what were you thinking during that time
and I was I was thinking that I was
gonna get him that I was gonna pull over
first and he was in a pull over after
and right when he comes out the door I
was gonna run up and slam the [ __ ]
door doors later until his [ __ ] leg
came off cuz that's the only way you
could do it because I don't know how big
he is I don't know anything else and so
at the time too I always had like a bat
and a baseball glove and some you know
makes it look like play baseball but I
just have a bat in this just for the
back so I'm just gonna [ __ ] start
smashing his [ __ ] car to pieces but
she she kind of like got me out of that
headspace and I haven't had like episode
six and I was like four years ago then
you know the difference between like
dating like a violent girl versus dating
like a good girl or whatever big you
want
so the violent girl will jump out the
car with you and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up she might even be the one that's like
inste trying to jump through the window
and you got a [ __ ] polar back by the
g-string you know who the [ __ ] my man is
full yeah it's gonna [ __ ] you up but I'm
in the back like no I'm not you didn't
ask me they're the ones pulling out a
[ __ ] knife in their purse and start
but then the good girl will be like you
made me feel unsafe No and that's that's
was like what I was trying to protect
you exactly wasn't nothing to protect I
was trying to protect my pride yeah what
it was there's like there's you made me
feel like saying yeah it made me feel
like oh this [ __ ] white guy thinks he
could talk to this asian dude however
the [ __ ] he wants
I'm gonna [ __ ] this fool up and that's
all I could think about yeah
now mind you if he was like mouthed
there's other times where I was on the
road and I didn't I wasn't mad or
anything but basically they cut me off
yeah mad at me and it was a bunch of
[ __ ] cholos like what's up fool right
and you could tell they do was like
pretending yeah it's for some [ __ ] I was
like I'm sorry you
oh yes I was so sorry
it's a my fart I suggest to come here
that's like also knowing when the
[ __ ] back down to is a bunch of dudes
this is a bunch of [ __ ] cholos tatted
up from the [ __ ] neck down and he's
like reaching down like this am I gonna
get mad and be like yo what's up
well [ __ ] though but if I see this
man in a [ __ ] Chrysler 300 why dude
you know trying to [ __ ] his Timothy was
a Bentley but it looked like it might
have been a Bentley but it was something
that it was something along the lines of
him driving something nicer than me
being a white guy talking to me like
that thing he could [ __ ] me um that made
me really really upset Dunham and today
like there's cameras there's no who's
armed you don't know it's just different
man you gonna kill me yeah doesn't mean
[ __ ] just not worth it no more yeah man
I think the only time I want to go ham
is my life's in danger someone's life is
in danger yeah we're like let's say like
oh I saw this one footage right this
[ __ ] [ __ ] creep me the [ __ ] out dude
[ __ ] is like burned into my mind but it
was like a Inside Edition video and like
this there's there's door footage of an
actual kidnapping going down like no
[ __ ] a guy just grabs does mom and
daughter eight-year-old daughter right
this man grabs the daughter and they
have a [ __ ] tug-of-war over the
daughter and then like it was caught on
a nest oven of like some people walking
across the street he manages to get her
in the [ __ ] car later
you know there's body cam footage of
police actually finding the car and then
like it was kind of later and a night
but they go to the hotel they [ __ ]
bust the door open they pulled the bad
guy out he's [ __ ] butt-ass naked and
the girl the little girls naked too and
they they found her in a laundry basket
or some [ __ ]
so something happened to her [ __ ]
unfortunately right but they found her
but I'm like that's some crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] happens it's crazy yeah I mean like
it you just never see it on camera but
like all those things they it does
happen right like people pull up with
[ __ ]
rate bands and pull people in and [ __ ]
how horny are you for kid [ __ ] that you
just run up and watch I'll from a from a
mother's hand right broad daylight and
for me I can't wait till the day that I
witness that and I ran my [ __ ] car
into this [ __ ] well if I do that
I might Ram the kid and the mom too you
know but that's great but if it's like I
see a kid in the car and I'll [ __ ]
slam my car I'll [ __ ] pull that
[ __ ] I'll kill him with my bare
hands you know and then it's okay to be
violent at that times a different
situation and people go you're a hero
but I'm just like no I just wanted to
kill someone because there's an Amber
Alert yeah we used to have like
fantasies like okay dude if there's a
Templar and we find this [ __ ]
yeah the first thing we do is call each
other hub so yeah do something about it
yeah because it gets exciting right
but it's like there are so many ugly
things that happen like that dude one um
I have a friend that I that was actually
almost kidnapped kidnapped oh sure yeah
she was waiting for the bus at a bus
stop late at night and um this was like
Boyle Heights area or whatever yeah and
then [ __ ] she says that a van like a
rape van just rolled up like those
[ __ ] big-ass cargo vans right and
then um a guy was like asking her hey do
you know how to get in whatever what and
as she was talking the [ __ ] van door
opened and a bunch of dudes bump like
just ran out and started trying to pull
her inside what the [ __ ] yeah and then
she was just [ __ ] fighting and
fighting and screaming and going [ __ ]
crazy right and then the bus came and
stopped in front of all that [ __ ] so
then they [ __ ] kicked her out of the
car closed the door and then drove off
oh yeah that's [ __ ] crazy I'll talk
to her no more but dude she did she had
her family just like left that area real
quick do man when these bad areas are
like that it's what we were just talking
about on the podcast where it's like I
always tell I don't always tell but I
said this before it's like it's sad that
that's the type of world that we live in
yeah and so when there's a conversation
sometimes and a lot of guys are very
poor and like phrasing these words but
it's like when you're in a bad area and
you're by yourself and you're a woman
it's a very dangerous place to be you
know oh yeah man and it's like well what
do you think women are weak it's like no
[ __ ]
it's because it's a bad area and they
prey on women like that ham you know
like that's that's not the conversation
really intent but you know it's just
like I see that sometimes I get [ __ ]
scared for women man that's like it's
scared from Muriel sometimes cuz she's
such a sweet sweet they don't know they
don't [ __ ] know that's why dude I'm a
GPS the [ __ ] out of my family he's like
where the [ __ ] at all times yeah no
Michael chip them [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that
say where's your microchip ease in your
[ __ ] ass you dumb ass imagine how
lucky you'd feel if you had a [ __ ]
Amber Alert microchip GPS on your damn
thigh and you slap that [ __ ]
when you get kidnapped and you're like
joke's on you [ __ ]
you better [ __ ] come quick cuz the
police is coming right now dude if I if
I ever have a kid dude if a daughter how
they make a really fat and ugly so
nobody wants to kidnap her be like ugly
kids get [ __ ] kidnapped
it's like looks don't don't matter that
a [ __ ] yeah that's just dangerous
that's crazy
I got no standards huh nah dude I think
for them it's a power trip cuz they're
very small people so they need to feel
big and they needed like take over
people like you wouldn't even do that to
like a dog on the streets like you were
gonna run up and just snatch snatch him
up but you would do that to like a young
kid like that yeah [ __ ] crazy
and now this was in a Dallas Fort Worth
yeah Texas crazy [ __ ] in a place with
all those guns to [ __ ] bold huh
that's true man somebody would have
[ __ ] shot at him yeah now that lady
should have had a firearm she's gonna
blast I know dude imagine dude I would
have [ __ ] rain bullets like a
[ __ ] but Josh the footage the
CCC the CCTV footage of you would have
been in slow-mo of you smiling like yes
it's a time [ __ ] you [ __ ] capping
[ __ ] into a bush just blah you
know the Chris Hanson 20/20 [ __ ]
that shows so funny dude imagine having
that but like you have a button and then
when the molester comes in you have the
little kid hit that button and in the
whole house goes [ __ ] locks up like
it's a like it's purge but then now
you're stuck in the house yeah I always
wanted to do something to where I know
this is such a dumb people when I was
younger I used to draw like all this
weird [ __ ] like it would be like a car
with 4000 rock yeah yeah yeah I I gotta
find those pictures but I have someone
in the back in my house but I also had
drew this other thing where when people
would you know [ __ ] with my parents in
the store I drew this contraption where
a cage would come down so the door would
lock a cage would come down and the
[ __ ] spikes would go inside some home
alone [ __ ] New York look at morbid as
child I'm like medieval times like if I
ever get to own this black bees blast
door when I ring it with [ __ ] booby
traps anybody tries to rob my parents
I'm just [ __ ] put a cage on him
playing [ __ ] and wait to the
caca
what are you Count Dracula and [ __ ] I
don't know that figure got some crazy
[ __ ]
Vladimir yeah so the [ __ ] next topic
that people want us to talk about since
we moved on from brother nature or Kevin
Pena yeah cut that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] out
man just be a good guy
so h3h3 right which by the way this guy
is hilarious I think this guy's [ __ ]
funny man yeah anything is [ __ ] funny
find dad and his wife plays like
counterparts him really well she
balances him really well yeah he'd like
dude he talks shits and the funniest
[ __ ] way man yeah I love this guy
dude I think he's just hilarious but um
the way he kind of like breaks things
down it's a lot of work on his part to
be honest with you yeah a lot of thought
and work so when I see his stuff people
like Oh anybody can do no you can't
because he actually does his research
yeah before he does like these videos
where he's clowning on somebody he he
has like the knowledge and the
information behind it I don't really do
that I just kind of clown on people but
are you talking about cuz now he has his
podcast like his videos back in the day
oh those were good when he's roasting
people funny yeah those were pretty good
and he had like evidence stacked on
people it was really dope but he
recently got flamed
for uh I guess he made some comments
about the kpop community specifically
like kpop fandom uh these days you can't
say nothing negative about kpop which is
so weird right because I guess what he
said to was a lot of the lines if he
doesn't understand how you know how
Western people find this like these guys
attractive or whatever or this whole
situate you know whatever whatnot right
yeah which in my opinion he's allowed to
have that [ __ ] opinion like what he
is but what's what's wrong with him not
understanding why music from a foreign
language with words they don't
understand yeah right would be more
popular in charting in this country than
it would in Korea yeah like it's it's a
it's a weird phenomena it is like I I
get it you know what I mean but I guess
you know he's making jokes about it he's
a comic like he makes [ __ ] jokes
about it and you know kpop people they
get so [ __ ] mad they're like oh my
god I can't believe that you he's like
I'm sorry that you don't think that
Asian men can be attractive he didn't
say that he didn't say that at all what
do you [ __ ] I'm Korean dude I love
Korean music like I don't I don't
understand the fandom behind it do you
know what he said exactly that's that it
was along those lines
it's probably nothing bad no ages we
blow it they just blow that [ __ ] up yeah
but I also feel like k-pop fans are like
unique yeah it's like all the fans are
madly in love with the people that they
love listening to so they're gonna
they're gonna defend their honey you
know to me like you don't talk to their
boyfriend that way
yeah you talk to their boyfriend that
way that way you're gonna get murdered
you know what I mean like they're all
having relationships with their with the
people that they [ __ ] watch yeah
first of all just like put this out I
mean I think for them they're like yeah
it's because their music helped you know
help me through all these problems and
or whatever whatnot you know I will say
this just come back down to reality for
a second I'm really glad that that music
can help you out a lot but number one
they're not your property like these
kpop people number two they don't give a
[ __ ] about you they don't give but to a
David they're 14 years old and in love
you don't [ __ ] with a 14 year old bat's
in love sad thing I think they're older
than that though are you serious okay
there's sixteen and in love alright you
don't [ __ ] with a sixteen year old girl
that's madly in love with her
one artist you don't tell her anything
negative weird - because they they like
we there's so much information and
knowledge out there
that you should be able to understand
who these k-pop people are right they're
like there's such amazing artists they
do this and that this and that it's like
they're all manufactured manufacturing
that's fun and you're like well how do
you [ __ ] know David bah bah bah blah
it's like I am in the entertainment
industry I know we know we know kpop
people we know kpop people like Lars
Lars and og kpop people and they've
we've had conversations about this they
work back behind the scenes they do
dance they work with them the Stars
everybody yeah like why do you think
these k-pop people have to open up
restaurants they have to make their
money elsewhere because they have 360
deals they are owned by these [ __ ]
companies except for a few people there
who are writers and stuff like they they
kind of made and pave their own way
which is a very small select few but you
know that there's [ __ ] like kpop rap
hog ones you know which is like those
study halls there's kpop rap hog ones
there's k-pop k-pop hog one it's it's
they're k-pop factories yeah they're
[ __ ] factories man yeah and this is
what's fed to you 24 [ __ ] 7 I'm not
saying that you shouldn't like your
things but it's so weird how how like
these people are gods to you like in
what [ __ ] way there was recently a
huge scandal or a bunch of these k-pop
guys they were having like sex rings
like like prostitution rings I would too
if I had have any girls just throwing
themselves at me and it's funny too
because I always even do it I will say
this though like the funny [ __ ] thing
too is like the same people who are such
hardcore k-pop fans and you know we
could have this conversation where we
say stuff like oh I'm not one of them
it's like cool you're not then you
shouldn't speak about this so the same
people who really love these kpop people
like this whole crazy kpop fan have
started from Korea like Korean people
were like this I just didn't think that
people in the West would have taken
these toxic behaviors because in Korea
if a kpop star like I remember there was
this one band member band member from
this band called h.o.t he if they found
out that he was dating somebody they
started sending that girl death threats
and death letters and they were sending
him letters that they were gonna kill
themselves if they don't break up yeah
that's what I'm saying these girls are
have they have relationships
and we're crazy yeah in their mind in
their mind they're in love that's why
you can't [ __ ] with a girl in love man
it's like I was shocked because that's a
whole army it was like these [ __ ]
little kpop medicines like in Korea I
thought they were Psychopaths and then
for some reason that negative culture
transferred over to the West because you
can't because love makes people crazy
that's [ __ ] insane they're in love
man and they're like oh my god they're
so perfect I'll say which one the one
that was [ __ ] prostitutes and then uh
selling women on the side is he perfect
too or what about the fact that some of
these like k-pop fans because when they
don't do something that you like you
start sending them death threats there
have been like three or four major
suicides of k-pop people because of
comments yeah in recent years yeah in
this this year Laura there was some
there was there was uh I forgot who she
was but she committed suicide and there
was another kpop star who was her best
friend
she also committed suicide as well I
mean you guys could probably put who
those who those girls are and there was
another guy whose and Amber's homie oh
yeah yeah another guy committed suicide
two and it's like it's funny how you
think that the culture that you're
developing is supporting these people
but that's only when it benefits you and
makes you feel good but the moment they
do something outside of what you do
because not only are they property to
the company that owns them and owns all
their music they're also your [ __ ]
property now too because then they don't
do what you want you go on these
comments you call them trash you tell
them they're [ __ ] ugly that they'll
never be popular again and they commit
suicide and then you cry about it it's
like dude this is like the worst worst
culture I've ever seen in my life it's
so terrible that's how crazy a
twelve-year-old girls emotions are and
it's not even - bro which is [ __ ]
crazy man and this dude Ethan why I like
about what I like about him he doesn't
back down he didn't say anything wrong
yeah and he's not gonna put out a pop a
public apology [ __ ] don't don't [ __ ]
do it this is what he just tweeted at
4:45 today I do not want him to ever
apologize for [ __ ] like he says my
message to kpop fans
lighten up nerds that's Thai if you
can't handle your hobby being made fun
of a little bit then you are really just
a bunch of little girls jerking off the
kpop boys exactly there's really what it
is here's another thing he goes
and the funny thing is like people think
they're all we're gonna cancel Ethan but
it's at the end of the day like you
can't cancel what you don't consume
exactly how are you gonna how you gonna
cancel that [ __ ] like if his own fans
won't cancel him exactly it's not his
fans know so like try to [ __ ] cancel
us go ahead fo you can't cancel me when
you don't even buy my [ __ ] dude number
five on Twitter trending was h3 h3 is
over party that's how strong their
fandom is and this photo was tweeted
back he goes number five trending y'all
were canceled lol it was a bunch of
crying faces dude like it didn't even
dent make a dent and it didn't even
affect this [ __ ] it might even be giving
him more fans now of course he doesn't
give a [ __ ] dude the opposite is
happening
maybe that's so genius maybe we should
talk [ __ ] about kpop and then we'll get
more fans
maybe the funny thing is is I like I
love Korean music man there's a lot of
like I grew up on a lot of these bands
and I'm not really like current with
some of these new bands and all these
other kids like because it's like young
pop [ __ ] I don't I don't like that music
but there's a yeah used to listen to
groups called my h.o.t g.od life Inc oh
that's the old school yeah ses like a DJ
doc ock jinusean fly to the sky shoutout
to the homie Bryan and there's a lot of
like people like it's cool because I
actually got to meet some of these
people who idolized when I was younger
and you know we become peers now Korean
pop has evolved so much those four
shirts man it's good like it's it's good
[ __ ] music oh yeah yeah there's
there's a there's a there's our like a
hip-hop group called epic high who I
think is [ __ ] dope they're [ __ ]
amazing man like it's just it's just the
fan and part is so we're just like you
can't take why do people have to like it
I don't understand why can't they not
like it they're like well you don't they
take one criticism of it and they make
it personal they go you don't like it
that means you don't think Asian guys
can be attractive it's like what what
the [ __ ] said that I just think it's
weird that all of them look like ghosts
and they have pink lips yeah I mean in
by Western male beauty standards right
it's not it's difficult for them to
understand because when they see them
they see him as like
in yeah it's pretty boys they're very
pretty they're prettier than the pretty
boys here yeah so that's why I think
it's difficult for them to understand
why you know Western women and Western
women is not white women it's Western
culture right so you could be like
latina black whatever but they all find
this new look attractive yeah and for me
I'm like [ __ ] better for me yeah I mean
I don't look like them don't have the
boyish pretty boy looks but yeah but
fantasize me I don't give a [ __ ]
but at the same time I'm like I'm like
that is kind of cool that that there's
this diverse look of guys you know you
got your more masculine rugged guy you
got your nerdy guy cuz nerds cool to now
you know you know like and then you got
your pretty boys and whatever it's gonna
keep evolving and changing cuz people
get bored of looks that's what that's
what they don't understand if you see
like every ten years the ideal woman
right like back in the 90s or the 80s
like it was big boobs and flat butts
yeah and now it's like big butts yeah
you know they're like a beauty always
change it just keeps changing and in the
shape of the face that how they do their
makeup or whatever and then guys - right
it's just overtime like things are just
gonna keep shifting yeah it's it's kind
of odd where like I just never
understood even when I was younger like
the the type just like how angry people
are it's like why are you so easy then
they don't one of these fans so [ __ ]
angry dude like I don't get it it's it's
like Eminem fans times 3,000 you know I
mean or like or Beyonce fans times 10
million I mean at the same time - I
didn't even know why the Asian like I
see like for me I like Asian American
look right yeah like I like Asian
American girls like their style whatever
more than I do
Asian girls from Asia because I think
Asian girls from Asia their style it
looks too childish like it's too younger
yes it's not our thing we don't like it
no but that's to them it's cute
right but I like also sex appeal and
they might have it but it's not I don't
know it's not Western right yeah so I
feel like that that's kind of the same
with the guys out there right like girls
that might like Asian guys like that are
non Asian or whatever they might look at
them and be like oh I don't know like
this is kind of different you're not
used to it but it's all about taste so
out in Asia I'm even confused cuz like
their idea of masculinity their idea of
what a good looking man is it's
different mm-hmm cuz it was our parents
generation that liked handsome men
handsome as in like more rugged chiseled
jawline like kind of like yeah a little
bit buffer or like and more I don't know
like a traditional idea of what a
masculine dude is that's more Western
maybe right and now it's more like
pretty boys and tall skinny pretty boys
and and and and more that kind of stuff
yeah yeah cuz I feel like what my
parents thought was attractive would go
in line with Asian Americans finding the
same things attractive mmm that's that
because even for I was just talking
about this with Muriel's best friends so
she she kind of like um she had this uh
this revelation of not too long ago
about how sometimes she could be really
harsh about you know where she is in her
life and in terms of fitness mm-hmm and
it's because and I was kind of telling
her a lot of the stuff that her and
Mariel didn't like about their bodies is
actually what we in my area in
Sacramento that's a [ __ ] that we like
about girls you know curvy women yeah
like when they're curvy they got ask
they got legs cuz she was talking about
like I had to accept the fact that I
couldn't have a Saiga and I was like why
exactly so you know but you know even
even this type of [ __ ] to you like even
like type of girls that jason chen like
he finds really attractive looks really
skinny like like Fabi looking girls yeah
yeah he likes the girls who just they
look more Asian centric they're very
very very thin he likes the girls with
the thigh gap yeah if he sees a thick
girl he doesn't
that they're attractive he wants them to
look like they're on the verge of death
that's like his [ __ ] you know like yeah
I like me
I like yeah so like even for her she
can't came to real she goes yeah I
understand that I'm just that's not my
body type that I'm not gonna have a
thigh gap you know my mind I was telling
her that's funny because in my area if
you had a thigh gap
ain't nobody find that should have tried
to deal on thick chicks so be like I
need to feed you yes I we we need to
girl with some kind of meat on there
yeah I need to grab some [ __ ] right and
that's why I like people's perception of
beauty is it's it's so different right
and that's why it's okay for for when
Ethan said like yo like I don't get this
it's okay for him not to get it man yeah
it's not like he's saying that they're
ugly they shouldn't get the girls
exactly goes I just I don't get it like
I don't understand why this like how why
Western how this how this got affected
so much by on Western so he's more
asking a question instead of luck
yeah this shouldn't happen I'm not
quoting took it as like they probably
took it as like this shouldn't happen
yeah cuz I'm not quoting him exactly but
I do distinctly remembers him saying
that along the lines that of him like I
don't understand how western people can
find us attractive which makes sense
because is the West I don't need but I
don't understand exactly I don't get
even because I'm a western guy yeah and
so when I go to Asia because even Asian
American girls don't find that
attractive
yeah but then like I don't know I it
goes in to race and all that stuff too
because like that we have Western beauty
standards yeah but I also don't think
that white women are always the
best-looking either
yeah or white men I just think that the
fashion the style of the body type that
western style yeah the mix of it is the
best yeah yeah I'm saying man I still
I'll never understand why I think
everybody else within that music genre
if they if like for example let's say we
said somebody came up to me goes yeah I
don't really [ __ ] with hip-hop I don't
go what the [ __ ] now be less [ __ ] well
great you like to limit yourself you
know you just got to move on well right
what the [ __ ] that means
that's what I'm saying is they're
probably all like 13 year olds man like
ask us when I was that age you talk [ __ ]
about my favorite movie
[ __ ] you wing friends yeah you talk [ __ ]
about my favorite artist [ __ ] you Ian
you know it might be a little bit same
today but then I won't I won't get mad
cuz I get tired because I'm old I got to
read some of these like tweets and
responses to do it for some of the stuff
that he said just because I want people
to get an understanding of how intense
these [ __ ] are dude and it's
the you know what the funny thing is
from like the same accounts dude oh dude
there's there's some [ __ ] like that
they they come after me too
they still coming after me [ __ ] damn go
to Hale let me see I'll join you on this
Ethan climb so you look at this like
even this it's it's so high and mighty
so all these accounts too that are
responding to them aren't even pictures
of their face know their favorite kpop
yeah their idol accounts and it's it's
so high and mighty like see if you
actually took the time to explore the
world of kpop let me explore them you
would be ashamed of your words already
this interested you will see the
devotion and hard work of both the
artist and the fans which the the
devotion the the hard work of the fans
and the fans which is amazing you'd also
see the love for one another between
both parties which is also beautiful
what the [ __ ] are you saying
you mean this song that they did it
right or produce or choreograph like yes
they do
they had their name on it that doesn't
mean [ __ ] dude that doesn't mean [ __ ]
that this is obviously kids cuz they
don't know how it works yeah although
you clearly don't care this love between
fans and artists has helped many of us
it gave us a reef to love and feel like
we're a part of something it gave us a
reason to want to live but you can't
look past that because all you see are
sad stereotypes even though I know you
won't see this I'm so highly
disappointed you've disrespected
something that has both given me a
reason and many others to live and to
love I just hope you someday change your
mind but it will most likely never be as
you've already made these remarks this
fool wrote that face when kpop stands
are trying to take the moral high ground
over a joke but are responsible for
dozens of suicides of k-pop idols
because of their online abuse that's
exactly what I said you gotta mean it
but critical do this is [ __ ] funny
man
oh man and you know also to it like like
I said I I'm I'm a I'm a Korean music
fan I love Korean music you know but I I
will never understand this type of
behavior this is [ __ ] anything and it
just like if you're even when I'm a part
of liking Korean music I can't help but
step back and laugh at the high and
mighty responses of like I there's a lot
of things that saves people lives
people's lives right but the reaction
that they get from not liking what they
like is it this isn't this it makes me
uh it makes me like set it's like yo you
may create you making cream people look
bad dude dude there's a Korean um I
think he's a journalist he's so he's
verified and he wrote why don't you just
call them chinks and get it over with
Ethan here's why you can't imagine
little girls and grown men jerking off
to little kpop boys what the [ __ ] asian
man is inferior to find white specimens
such as yourself he said this is why you
can't imagine people talking kids turkey
not the kpop what does that mean
that's disgusting what would you say
that no he says that Ethan said little
girls and grown men jerking off to
little kpop boys but I think the weird
thing was how he phrase ego this is why
you can't imagine it it's like you
shouldn't imagine that [ __ ] dude what
the [ __ ] are you saying we phrased that
sentence dude well he's okay so he he is
a award-winning Rolling Stone
damn dude so he took it pretty personal
to Jay Kim who's Jacob he's the he's the
guy that wrote all that is he a kpop guy
uh I think he's a journalist he's
verified well yeah so he might he might
just peace firing he's mad he's saying
Ethan's a racist
why is he racist though I don't know I
don't know but that was the first
legitimate person I saw respond to him
yeah he's a actual journalist you know
maybe maybe we're not quoting him
correctly because somebody Rosia like it
would have been fine if you may fund
them for their music or performance or
whatever but you had to bring race into
it and be super xenophobic and
homophobic and what's
I guess cuz he might have maybe he
called him gay or something you called
him gay
maybe damn I'm one of these kids even
know what [ __ ] xenophobia is they're
just using it yeah xenophobic
I forgot what is xenophobe I forgot that
[ __ ] what is that
so if you look up well let me not
slaughter it for people yeah we got to
look up the definition cuz if I say it
and the verbage is a little wrong
they're gonna [ __ ] chew me up in the
[ __ ] comments so xenophobia is the
fear or hatred of that which is
perceived to be foreign or strange Oh
so xenophobia can involve perceptions of
an in-group toward an out-group and can
manifest itself in suspicion of the
activities of others and a desire to
eliminate their presence to secure a
presumed purity and may relate to a fear
of losing national ethnic or racial
identity yeah I guess that that fits
yeah that fits but it's so funny but I
don't think it does because he's not
trying to like do you see I'm saying oh
I mean yeah yeah yeah that he's not
being xenophobic but then like the
percept if if the negative perception is
true it is xenophobic Oh gotcha
okay what you're saying it's so
interesting man it's crazy how out of
hand that's God and like I said man
everybody's entitled to their opinion if
they if they feel like his joke was
really harsh then you're allowed to feel
that way but I guess if I can side with
them saying that he's racist it's kind
of like duh you won't understand because
white guys had a hard time understanding
beauty standards outside of the Western
world yeah I guess that's kind of like
the age-old thing like the only standard
isn't the own the Western standard and
it's like your outdated fool because
pretty much kpop and and and beautiful
Korean men and and that trend has been
going around for a [ __ ] over a decade
now that's just been around I think I
think he found out what he said you
found it
how did this become a thing in Western
culture where all these grown men Oh
little girls are jerking off the little
kpop boys a fetish about these kpop
[Music]
indie like kpop what do you think about
BTS I mean I don't like it but I don't
know I don't like the kind of the blends
they do of like hip-hop and then like
really not that interesting music but I
see why people like because that's what
I know do people are crazy on Twitter
the k-pop fans day well it's so weird
all they do is post a gif of their
favorite like kpop person dancing and
they go [ __ ] crazy like I'm pretty
sure that somebody's gonna try to
assassinate me very cold get out yes we
said yes so he did say the twink gay
baby is that the part that really pissed
people off I don't know none of that
sounded offensive to me but I'm not a
kpop star it just seemed like somebody
who doesn't get get it and that's okay
and then he made a like I mean you know
you could take that and take it however
you want but it just seemed like a
little hurt my feelings my figures I'm
Asian and I'm Korean yeah I mean yeah
you know and I love Korean music so I
didn't find that offensive but I can't
speak for everybody else like I just I
guess what I don't like is that this it
just makes I think it just makes Korean
people look bad
but are the fans that are pissed Koreans
though they're white people that
fetishize Asian people I think so is
that why they have the [ __ ] idol
accounts and they don't show their face
cuz they're all whites pretending to be
Korean I honestly feel and they're all
white people attacking this Jewish guy
yeah he's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah but a lot of these people who are
attacking him or people who aren't
Korean people oh I think even Korean
people like I get it why this [ __ ]
white Jewish [ __ ] doesn't like this [ __ ]
it's not it's not his thing but then you
know people in the states tend to have
you know when it comes to like racial
things yes this was a racial thing to
them you know it was xenophobic you know
Vic as well that like white Jewish
people are considered white now yeah and
they're not they're not really right or
they weren't always in that category
yeah Jewish people were [ __ ] hated by
white people yeah better than what if
you guys don't know about the Holocaust
and they're not really considered like
like purebred white and you know is just
I mean like in America though when it's
like well you do look like one of them
compared to someone that's like dark or
black or Latino then they throw them in
that white category man race is just
such a funny ass issue dude in this
country it's really such a hot [ __ ]
top dude I went back and forth with this
one guy on Twitter because he kept
calling this Jewish person a white white
supremacist yeah and I was like by
definition he can't be a white
supremacist because he's Jewish
yeah and he kept saying like well look
at his skin and this and that and I'm
like no like look at the definition of
white supremacy like even in a doctrine
the number one most did you know like if
you think about Nazism or white
supremacy right the number one group
that they hate is actually Jewish people
it's not black it's not Mexican it's not
Asian the top top people that they hate
Jews it's Jewish yeah so but in this guy
that I was going back and forth with he
didn't know his history so he was
calling this Jewish man a white
supremacist and I was like how the
[ __ ] irony like how and he goes well
and then they and then they they
backtracked and said well even you know
they could be a sympathizer so you can
be a black white supremacist you can but
I hate when people do that it was like
and so if you're helping there
then you're a white supremacist and I'm
like so I can be one okay [ __ ] dude
that's so [ __ ] stupid you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] supremacist dude I know you
[ __ ] [ __ ] supremacist I hate your guts
but Bart was like hey man we should be
Asian supremacist I'm like what
he's like cuz cuz this is back in high
school not like collagen [ __ ] he's like
we gotta be like Asian supremacists and
I'm like what do you mean because when
you walk into a room you gotta feel
superior then everybody come all like
Bart Bart says some of the [ __ ]
funniest [ __ ] like the BART that was um
this is what I believe a lot of people
can change for the better you hear all
these [ __ ] Bart stories and you see
who the man that he turned out to be now
it's you would have never guessed night
in [ __ ] day
so once told me this story that him and
you know the guys buddy Alec yeah so it
was Ryan yeah it was Ryan they went
[ __ ] wanted to go spearfishing so
they they couldn't go fishing so they
bought a bunch of dead fish from the
supermarket
yeah they threw it into his pool got
some spear guns it started blasting
these dead fish to the pool just turn
the [ __ ] hell yeah and they were
chipping the swimming pool yeah and the
mob comes out and flips the [ __ ] out I
mean what made you think that was a good
[ __ ] idea dude I'm like oh god dude
no no no I understand no I get it Markus
fear them these are the spearfishing
gonna pull and now they they only have
to dump all that water out and then put
fixed pool
oh my god dude so people can change
listen yeah before I get [ __ ] roasted
by kpop fans number one I'm [ __ ]
Korean and to listen to creamiest before
you have before you roasted by all these
white kids that are trying to speak in
behalf of Koreans yeah [ __ ] okay say
kashibai let me look and tell me what I
can eat like I'm gonna suck my [ __ ]
caught you [ __ ] cancel my other I'm
gonna get cancelled by [ __ ] white
people telling me how I should feel
about my cultures music shut the [ __ ] up
first of all all right you could talk
about your k-pop idols that you like
they're probably homies of mine so [ __ ]
you anyways like yeah
before I get [ __ ] canceled about the
[ __ ] I think that it's okay for you to
feel a certain way when you're very
young and people don't like the things
that you like because you're young and
you're very emotional but it's okay for
people not to understand something that
you understand because it's a world that
you're in I don't think he's [ __ ]
zena phobic all right I think that's a
stretch I think he just doesn't [ __ ]
know yeah he doesn't know he doesn't he
doesn't understand why the [ __ ] does he
have to like kpop why does no one has to
like it nobody does and and kpop boys
are very pretty they are like if one of
them wanted to suck my dick I might be
like me for that [ __ ] - what the [ __ ]
yeah man like we even have like
what's-his-name from like yeah they're
not gonna suck your dick before mine I
know like why would he suck your dick
you fat ugly [ __ ] yo shout-out to a jay
from day six mm-hmm love that kid by the
way mm-hmm he's so [ __ ] pretty he's a
handsome handsome man very [ __ ]
talented I didn't realize how talent he
was until I met him at the JK office and
he was like big fans of yours I'm like
oh that's super dope and I saw him
[ __ ] talented singer dude kids
[ __ ] dope yeah he came down or I mean
our editor was working with them doing
all of his videos all that stuff yeah
yeah really really cool kid man who
loved that guy I feel like they all
spend like a very disciplined routine on
their skincare cuz they all have perfect
skin yeah so a buddy of mine told me
he's a he's a kpop dude he said that
before they go out and they start doing
all the stuff they have to go through
like a six month to a year skin regimen
oh my god yeah so it's like before our
show we're gonna do a skin care
treatment playing for a year as they
become their kpop star and they're going
through their camp like a six month to a
year skin regimen that gets like rid of
all their pores smooth out smooth out
their skin it's like the whole laser
treatment type of thing damn I need to
get that [ __ ] done yeah it's pretty
intense but you know you can't you have
to upkeep it a lot because not one
treatment oh you do it one month and the
next month you don't know the one I want
to that I want kpop skin pure as snow I
want to be wider than this [ __ ] wall
right now Matt cuz I want to be white
okay I want to be porcelain
white you can't go out in the Sun for
like the first month really oh I already
failed them yeah it's it's it's like
some serious [ __ ] I want to look like a
[ __ ] plate like a corel plate I
want to look man uh because when I was a
baby like I had hella light skin yeah
like I was a Gauss dude yeah
fourteen years old I smoked [ __ ]
crack in the house play video games
stayed home all day [ __ ] never saw
the Sun I maintained some ghost skin
yeah when you don't wouldn't you look at
Jason Chen dude this kid is amazing man
he'll never get sunlight he got he's
always blushing with those rosy ass
cheeks I want to slap the [ __ ] blush
Marie Antoinette is [ __ ] yes always
looking like but that wraps up this
podcast guys thank you for those topics
just to wrap up those thoughts for me
number one I get why you can be upset
when somebody doesn't like your [ __ ] but
I think it gets a little bit out of hand
when it comes to Korean music I
understand that when music affects you
it feels like it lifts you up people
feel that same way about Eminem's music
but the way you attack people when they
don't understand what you like is a
little bit extreme I think it's a little
crazy and sometimes your fandom goes
it's positive because you support these
people and you put money in their
pockets but when they don't like what
you do you start calling them [ __ ]
you start [ __ ] shaming them and they
end up not being able to really just
like kind of package the [ __ ] in their
head right and you know they end up like
committing suicide so if you want to
take the responsibility of also
supporting them you should also take a
responsibility for how you've kind of
single-handedly destroyed their mental
health as well yeah so there's a lot of
things to say about that just enjoy the
music yeah enjoy the music man shut the
[ __ ] up egg that's what I say enjoy it
shut the [ __ ] up and move on yeah man
and you know I know a big comments gonna
be like those aren't real kpop fans or
the real k-pop fans don't really care
well who's to say that you can't tell
them that kpop fans they are kpop fans
if they like the music they're k-pop
fans yeah man like just because I mean
you might be the more sane one they all
try to re
report my tweets - they stayed up [ __ ]
none of them got [ __ ] canceled so
[ __ ] you
quitters on my side shoutout to a Kevin
Pena stop doing stupid [ __ ] man be that
positive dear [ __ ] guy and just stay
that way man what you doing dude - cut
the [ __ ] out I'm circling tough guy to
jump people at a sandwich shop done yeah
eat a sandwich which a girl yeah relax
anyways guys you could catch this catch
you could catch us on Spotify iTunes and
you see us on iTunes give us that five
stars there's any hot top as you guys
wants to talk about send it our way
and we'll get on it baby okay bye bye
peace